This is a short story of
maybe the quickest turnaround
I've ever experienced, ever.
Here you're seeing a
very fine image made
by the researcher at Stanford.
I'm not going to muck up
her name and I apologize.
Please do see her credit.
This is a solar
voltaic device that we
decided to try to quickly
get attention for, which
was very exciting research.
So they sent me a
few of these cells.
And I literally had
just a few hours
to try to attempt
an MIT homepage.
So I made an image
of just one device.
I actually used a stereo
microscope to make the image.
But I could absolutely
have done the same
with a camera and a 105 lens.
I just thought it
would be interesting
for you to see
this little story,
even though I did
not use a camera.
And then I placed
it in Photoshop
and just duplicated
a few of the layers,
just to sort of get a feel
for what I might want to do.
And I wound up developing an
image with layers of the cells
and moved them around.
I was in a mood for lavender.
So, sure enough, the MIT
office did use it online.
But eventually, I was
looking for the homepage
and wanted to suggest
something solar-like.
So I used a gradient
in the background.
I really didn't like that.
And then I remembered
from my thousands
of slides of images
of the landscape,
that I did, in fact, have a
sunset from California, that I
took many years ago on film.
And so I used that
for the background,
overlaid the various
layers that I previously
made of the solar cell,
cropped it a little bit.
And eventually,
they did, in fact,
use it for the MIT homepage.
This took all of,
I'm not kidding,
three hours from start
to finish, very unusual.
See if you could do it.
I challenge you.